Universal's 1999 remake of "The Mummy"
was a cultural reset for both the property
and Hollywood as a whole. It arguably changed
action movies, helping usher in the era of CGI
villains and heavily comedic heroes. One of
those heroes, Rachel Weisz's Evelyn Carnahan,
propels the action of the first "Mummy" film.
She is the one who recognizes the significance
of the puzzle box that leads them to the city of
Hamunaptra. She reads the incantation that awakens
Imhotep, and it is her soul that the undead priest
wants to give his dearly departed girlfriend.
Evelyn is a huge part of the
"Mummy" franchise's appeal.
Fans love the movie's blend of action, romance,
and comedy — all of which Weisz contributes to.
She channels screwball comediennes of
the '30s for her sparkling performance.
The Stranger noted in its review how
perfect she was to play Evelyn, saying,
"[She has] all the spunk and ditzy charm
you'd expect from a heroine who can
proudly proclaim she's not
just smart. She's a librarian!"
The "Mummy" series arguably fell off when
Weisz failed to return for "The Mummy:
Tomb of the Dragon Emperor," the third installment
in the "Mummy" series. A representative of Weisz
told Digital Spy that she didn't want to go
to China and spend so much time away from her,
at the time, newborn son. After
leaving the "Mummy" franchise,
Weisz went on to work steadily
in movies both big and small.
But her most critically acclaimed work of late
has been on a much smaller scale than "The Mummy."
Rachel Weisz won an Academy Award not
long after "The Mummy Returns" for her
performance in the 2005 adaptation of
John Le Carré's "The Constant Gardener."
The film centers on Ralph Fiennes' Justin Quayle,
who tries to solve the murder of his wife.
Weisz plays the ill-fated wife,
Tessa, an Amnesty activist in Kenya.
Weisz also has had some brief dalliances with
other blockbuster franchises post-"Mummy." The
same year she starred in "The Constant Gardener,"
she made a foray into comic book adaptations with
the cult favorite "Constantine." She'd go
on to star in "The Bourne Legacy," opposite
Jeremy Renner, before doing her time in the MCU,
playing Melina Vostokoff in "Black Widow" in 2021.
Vostokoff is something of a mother figure
to Scarlett Johansson's Natasha Romanoff
and Florence Pugh's Yelena Belova. As of
yet, there's been no word if Vostokoff
will return to the MCU, but there's little
doubt fans would adore seeing her again.
While Wiesz's experience with
blockbusters is extensive,
her most notable work of late
has been in more indie fare.
Weisz first worked with Greek director Yorgos
Lanthimos on his 2015 black comedy "The Lobster."
She played a woman searching for love before she
gets turned into an animal. She would reunite with
Lanthimos for 2018's "The Favourite," in which she
plays Lady Sarah Churchill. Lady Sarah starts the
film as the titular "favourite" of Queen Anne,
played by Olivia Colman, as well as her secret
girlfriend. Emma Stone plays Abigail, who woos the
Queen away from Lady Sarah in an attempt to stay
in power at court. Colman won an Academy Award
for her performance as Queen Anne, the apex of
the unlikely love triangle, while Stone and Weisz
were both nominated for Best Supporting Actress.
The same year as "The Favourite,"
Weisz starred in "Disobedience,"
opposite Rachel McAdams. The drama
focuses on two women from the Orthodox
Jewish community who try to reconcile their love
for each other with their sometimes overbearingly
strict community. Despite being married to a
man—Daniel Craig, a.k.a. James Bond— Weisz's
performances in these films have vaulted Weisz
into queer icon status in the LGBTQ community.
Weisz's queer turn may have something to do
with the fact that she's primarily focused
on women-centered stories.
She told the New York Times,
"I really enjoy all the thousands of
movies I've seen about men [...] I mean,
there are some great masterpieces.
But there's just a dearth of ones
about women. I love women. Women are just
really fascinating and different to men."
Fans can likely expect this trend to
continue with Weisz's future projects.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.